[Music]
chicken wash doing mouth keys today is a
very special day Chris because we're
having a Thai fried chicken today we
also have a guest who has the fun part
of this guest I don't even know his name
why did you just find their entire
person chicken showdown and we got a
guest today I make podcast anti-american
and like a restaurant I love to eat ha
ha
all right let's do this Wow thank you
you all make a Thai fried chicken it's
our signature dish it's called hot guy
fried chicken hi guys oh wow yeah it's
the name of the city so it became to the
name of rice chicken and why do you make
it here I love it
what should we be looking for in the
taste like what's gonna stand out to us
this one is more like a little bit
Indian forever
we have Christy shower on top it's very
famous like you can have in like many
province in southern part of Thailand oh
my dad's from the Northeast the Isan
region so I'm use of those flavors but
South has love like different spices and
what gives it that flavor exactly galaxy
Lando
[Music]
she doesn't want me to tell everything
okay good night that the night on I can
see where there's on the secret you'll
never know will you
[Music]
[Applause]
couple hot guys in hi hi chicken
[Applause]
[Music]
bout to hit it hard you can call me a
mallet
give me a Brad I'm chucking jelly so
what's the process of cooking the
chicken so we gonna marry nandan what's
the marinade cilantro flowers by comstar
garlic powder sauce fish sauce and soy
sauce
we burned everything and then we got
marinade I've never blended cilantro
before neither I I always cut it by hand
I feel like I would be lazy if I didn't
not that you're I'm not saying that
about you you know what you're doing
you marinate it all night then you get
here in the morning what do you do with
it
we wrapped into under the skin
everywhere so it's in every part of the
chicken yeah okay it's kinda kisses
yummy yummy yum in my tummy time I've
never seen fried chicken that's green it
smells incredible yeah it smells it
smells very potent and so sensual about
I'm saying this like the scenes of ghost
[Music]
girl I want to marinate you
[Music]
you look good those legs I wanna be your
number one guy who gets it now and just
rubs you up and then covers you with a
bunch of green so let's get to the brine
chicken wash all right and how long do
you fry it for Oh until it's done till
it's done I like that time man Wow green
chicken it's like a sexy villain like
really sexy looking but underneath
there's something mysterious something
like poison ivy revived chicken that
James Bond eats halfway through the film
till I get secrets but then that you can
betray him oh you think it was more of a
seductress I also don't know if I've
ever seen James Bond eat fried chicken
[Music]
chicken watch watch chicken watch all
the ugly can't fell down should we try
that let's try it plane first with the
shallots just to just to get the idea of
what it tastes like without in the
sausage all right chicken watch chicken
watch three one oh wow
different type of crunch yeah there's a
very little batter it's not like a shell
the flavor on it I'm have a hard time
describing it cuz I haven't had fried
chicken it tasted like this I thought
this cilantro taste was gonna be more
prevalent
there's certainly subtle has this really
juicy quality while still having a
really good texture but it has a quick
bite you know it fights back a little
bit normally chickens dredge like crazy
right is a ton of batter wasn't really a
dredging process it's mostly just the
skin of the chicken itself that's giving
you a lot of the crunch which is really
fun and great I'm gonna try this with
some sauce mmm
yeah that sauces does it oh that's so
good this one is no normal that's a
normal size so mighty fine it's spicy
they don't have normal and spicy they
have normal and then not spicy normal is
to be fair I'm actually gonna give my
sexy nod to the sauce it looks pretty
hot looks pretty cute and then you get
it in your mouth and by golly a sort do
a different world the spicy one isn't
that spicy it's still pretty mild to me
yeah yeah I was born with a normal tone
so what goes into this sauce chili and
garlic vinegar and vinegar sugar and
sugar a Lobel love yeah they said the
sticky rice yeah
plus the sauce plus the chicken plus the
shallots that's the way to go I'm gonna
get a little bit sticky rice uh-huh I
got a little chicken dipping it in the
sauce I've got some rice in my thumb
here shall it taste delicious
yes it's Shou
oh that's good it's so good have you
tried the combo party yet with the rice
where you get rice you got a I've tried
the combo party I did at the same time
with you I can't see you over there keep
think you're ahead of me yeah shook my
head at you would literally said I'm
doing it with you oh yeah I had the same
exclamation as you I was like wow the
last episode we had a little bit of
relationship trouble she didn't want to
be up by 7:15 and then at 7:30 was 738
chicken doesn't make people break up
Britt go wow really wow really but we're
back together but sometimes Chris still
forgets about the things that we do
together I'm sorry you're far away okay
feel like Quincy is coming between us a
little bit what's introducing me into
this thing playing your idea I don't
want it to be my idea if you're gonna
turn this into it's on my fault type of
a thing like I have enjoyed your
presence here I think it's been great
but also of your presence is detracting
from Chris and i's relationship then
yeah maybe you shouldn't be here keep
those for you huh let's try the pink
milk it's like our version of nest
playing yeah it's really good it tastes
like a like ice cream or something yeah
it's it's the salaat fruit swap so la
sala sato so that's a lot of flavor it's
a lot to handle chicken watch 2k15 for
ya where does this rank in your normal
experience of having the hot guy
[Music]
for me that massive amounts of shallots
are delightful well then you have it
like what the sauce you get to sleep and
then like the papaya salad you have like
salty and sour and spicy and you got all
those things going on to me like that
that combination factor is that's the
love right that's the combination factor
you can be a sexy not on your own but
you need something to acknowledge that
sexy nod and become a WOW factor love
has a lot of parts right it starts with
a crush it's not for the crime punch and
then you start to appreciate all the
aspects but then you find out that
everything individually is great but
when you put everything together it's
something special
and sometimes it seems like things are
coming between you but maybe it's just
another thing you need to add to the
combo my hands are really sticky so I'm
trying not to touch your coat I wasn't
as courteous no my left shoulder is all
right well it's all right with me that's
all right with me syncing what chicken
watch what a chicken day what a chicken
dead down what a chicken day what a
chicken day day what a day what a day
day
I wonder why they're so tasty I don't
think they were very patient in use I'm
a flower power part of me Superman I'm
making a fried chicken video what
question we asked everybody is do you
think that Thai fried chicken is the
best fried chicken in the world I think
it's one of the best wrong with one of
the best for a second I thought you're
about to be like yep ours is the best
that I would have been I think you yeah
for me I think you were right there's
something about the combination oh it's
like speed dating okay you know it
because cuz you're jumping around doing
quick things you have a lot of little
relationships but ultimately you
remember the whole experience I'd say
the crunch is really good saltiness and
the shoe graça tea is really good but
the metaphors have antennae attack well
that was it
what a great adventure on shake it one
hey where'd it go the chicken ha ha ha
well we'll see you next time let's get
out of here Keith
fun day Chris yeah do you think the
audience is gonna notice that we haven't
talked about the rubric at all so maybe
instead of the wow factor we're looking
for the love factor oh and the wow
factor though because who always bets
that's part of the it's part of the
criteria you know we wouldn't just want
to give like a random criteria for
tasting food we need to be very specific
gracious cific this is a very specific
well-thought-out scientific method it's
not just something we improvised one
time and stuck with yeah that'd be
foolish in a terrible business model
that wouldn't be a good food show